m
[Musique]
oh
un couteau - cocu et et aux figues et je
m'habille call sang-froid il m'a fallu
j'avais tous les jours un problème à
résoudre
je me demande où ils sont tous frappés
ya personne dans ce palais aujourd'hui
en fait je vois l'attitude enfin te
voilà manta moi j'ai vu personne de plus
ce matin beiba le rugby chic où tout le
monde est mobilisé pour préparer le
mexique au promu renouvelle ya peu nul
est bien sûr mais oui le grand gars
quand on met tout le monde et tu es
convaincu au me sembles - vador
mauvaises herbes à l'ancien flic du
personnel il me dit et rien n'y fait
titus et j'étais même un pique nique est
un grand plaisir pour moi grand dakar
est alors mosca ouais sont les
préparatifs et il a faim et je m'en
occupe
l'éthique et je suis débordée titus je
suis déporté veux tu allais voir si
bella ciao à préparer les sandwichs dit
ouais bon alors ensuite tueur à
surveiller ceci et cela
ils font cuire le rôti et ensuite tu
viendras me retrouver derrière le trône
du grand yaka dorothée pourvu que tout
soit prêt est dispensé de bitume encore
un petit effort et baby show et
terminerait alors net en algarve 512 ou
santé mais bon je dhabi suis arrivé trop
tard
ils sont fils du tarn et instable mais
vous les avez vous tout naturel vous
dans mon estomac voyons quoi vous voilà
de quoi vous l'adamaoua
tous sans exception selon des membres de
bosca il m'a dit fait descendre riche et
terminale a rapidement tu te rends chose
titus te rends compte 250 sandwich à
malin en cinq minutes pour dames effet
pas mettre à mal car joseph 1 et j'en
suis fier
à présent je vais faire une petite
promenade digestive le temps du grand
art 4 à 4 face et le rôti pour vous
collomb
après mon parent et quand c'est le rôti
du grand iata ici se trouve qu'il en
reste ici ici ou là b mauvais départ et
p sinon je vous mets à la brosse
panneaux sandwich
pas d'euro t il faut que vous prévienne
mon cas voyons il ne faut rien oublier
une couverture des couches 1 alors alors
alors titus tout est terminé on est 100
% pour faire tout est terminé fini à
sauver oui voilà ce que j'ai pu sauver
mais je vais me chez toi mon ce cas mon
bien-aimé pingouins l'étoile à un motif
et le mauvaises nouvelles annoncées mais
avons nous perdu les dix minutes
rien n'est prévu un pique nique wascat
mais ça lui bon outil wascat
je suis désolé c'est une catastrophe
la hotte de baffin annonce comme nom
laisse moi faire je vais arroser pas ne
vous veux pas imaginer qu'il ait pas
prier il peut plus belliqueux je mets
mes jeunes riches et beaux si grands
latin pour tes presse voici votre pique
nique commun mais je te gauche
oui grand gars un os superbe de l'élan
total le repas complet il m'avait
économique avec un autre comme celui ci
vous en avez pour x 30 ou 40 buts ni
chez nous avait fait le pique nique à la
mode grand encore
titus apporte-moi sait tous qu être le
monde avait tendance comme ça vous avez
le plus beau pique nique du monde et
c'est ce que je compte un petit sujet du
big data
je fais le pique nique à la voix de moi
et moi l'anru l'amant faro mai et après
après c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]